hence right down I'm still on this
question the amount of salt leaving the
typhoon yeah that's it that's the end of
salt going so now Part D just put your
pin down for a moment
Part D then gives you a um show this
right now when I have a look at this I'm
still my brain is still not clearing
into how is this exponential growth and
decay I mean I have some faith because
my teacher has given me a title that
says here's such right but what in this
makes it exponential growth and decay
when you have a look at the equation in
Part D hopefully you recognize that kind
of equation what were we introducing
yesterday do you remember why we're
talking about this what's different
between this and normal exponential
growth indicate normal exponential
growth in K right things tend towards 0
or from 0 you go up right but here
there's like an environmental factor
here that's changing what's going on
namely how much what is going in and how
much is coming out ok so let's have a
look at their equation it says DQ on DT
let's write that down D Q on D T that's
what it wants to work with now think
about what Q and T represent I've got
written on my diagram have you got it
written on your diagram what is Q it's
the salt which salt there's like three
different salts here this salt is salt
in this sold out which salt is it it's
the salt that's currently in the tank
currently in the tone right so that's
this quantity here right now it's
changing right is it increasing or is it
decreasing this is a question for you
increasing or decreasing the amount of
salt in the water is it increasing or
decreasing it's it's increasing because
I started with with no salt right what
where did the question told me that
there was no salt it was pure water okay
so this is going up what is making it go
up
i salt going in right that comes from
here soul is flowing in at this rate
okay so I know that's making it change
right that's the salt flow in but also
salt is being taken out at the same time
do you agree how much have a look at the
previous question that's why they
scaffold at this for us right this is
how much is being taken out at any given
moment does that make sense since I'm
taking it out what operations should I
put in you it should be
- that's reducing the amount of salt
that you okay with that qu on a thousand
if you recall back to when we're doing
rates have changed right at the
beginning and you get a derivative and
you're it's negative this is one of the
reasons why I encourage you to say don't
just say it's a negative interpret that
thing form you tell me what's going on
because I want you to think in terms of
increasing decreasing not just pluses
and minuses okay maybe for your own sake
because you're going to come back to
this working and wonder where that line
came from you might like to write that's
salt in and that's salt out that's where
those two figures came from okay now
have a look how am I going to get from
this to what they've told me have a look
at there's a result there that they want
you to prove what are you going to do
what's the difference between whatever
its factorization right that's the only
difference
so because this is a show question I'm
gonna be super slow about it I'm gonna
take out the negative W first so that
negative sign being taken out means I
can switch the order of my two terms so
that'll leave Q on a thousand at the
front and minus two at the back is that
okay factorization you're right with
that this is a sufficiently small step
for you what do I have to do to get from
there to there result I'm gonna take out
the oh the honor the division by a
thousand right so minus negative no II
on a thousand and that leaves me with
tada
oops another zero what I was after
how are you feeling
this question didn't start with here's
an exponential growth and decay model
tada off you go
okay it started really far away from
that we had to wrap our head around all
of this but hopefully we recognize this
is just like it might as well be
Newton's law of cooling right it's the
same kind of idea in here your rate of
change is proportional to this
difference here between how much salts
in there and how much thought you put in
you okay so I'm gonna get rid of my
beautiful diagram now so I can handle
space that's a shame let's have a look
at Part II
what's a asking us great show that q
equals now you can do this you don't
need my help to do this this is where an
exponential growth and decay question
usually begins isn't it right they give
you an equation if Q equals that is it
negative or is it WT on it
yep this is where the question usually
begins right but they could totally ask
all of this and if you saw it you'd be
like whoa what do I do with all this
well it's trying to get you to this
point okay
now I'm going to let you go ahead and
you can prove it how am I going to show
that this satisfies my differential
equation what will I do to it all you
need to do is differentiate and a tiny
bit of algebraic rearrangement okay
but as you do that they don't ask us to
this but I just want to UM I just want
us to graph this can we graph it just
roughly what is this thing going to look
like hmm think about it as you put put
together your couple of lines are this
this mm here what does this do to a
graph of an exponential function this is
my own yeah this is my Q axis oh here's
my time axis it raises the entire graph
up right so instead of my asymptote
which is normally at 0 my answer is
going to be at at Q equals 2,000 up here
so let me just arbitrarily call that Q
equals 2,000 okay now then you have a
look oh wait a second that's a minus
sign is that it -
no it's a plus-one it's okay if you have
a look at this guy over here right what
effect are you going to have when you
have a look at this equation over here a
as you're going to work out do they ask
you oh no we haven't I need you put it
okay let's just leave that there for a
moment you'll see why how do you prove
putty have you differentiated you've
rearranged that's pretty standard so I'm
not even gonna bother writing it for you
we need to determine the value of a so
there's this constant here right what
kind of information do we have in the
question that allows us to work out a
it's gonna pause there and let you have
a think about it you need to use some
kind of condition that connects time
with the amount of salt is there any
time when you know how much salt there
is in the take we actually we actually
mentioned it earlier right the initial
condition is commonly it's not always
but it's commonly the result they give
you right so initial means at when
rather T equals zero how much salt is
there we talked about it for zero it's
pure water so Q equals whoops where am I
writing one Q equals zero okay so you
can pop that into this equation we've
just been provided and you can use that
to find out a value of a when you do
that can someone tell me what you've
gotten
okay now I'm ready to graph this thing
sorry I was a bit ahead of myself I got
excited I like graphing if this is the
value of a okay so now I can actually
say that Q is equal to 2000
- mm e to the all this stuff what does
this thing look like hmm when you put a
negative in front of an exponential
right for example if you don't have to
write this down if instead of graphing
this which I hope we all know what that
looks like you've got an image in your
brain of what that looks like
if I instead asked you to graph this
what difference would that make its
flipped which way is it flipped its
flipped look carefully
that minus sign actually is mucking
about with the Y it's a vertical flip
isn't it okay and that's why you can see
I'm actually going to be not above this
asymptote like the exponential usually
is I'm actually going to be beneath the
absent Oh below it okay in addition to
that you don't just have that minus sign
which flips it vertically you also have
that minus sign over there which flips
it horizontally you see it's mucking
about with the T axis okay so that means
instead of like push it's going up it's
going to go down so in fact this here we
go is what you're going to get now
this is why I wanted this picture
because even though they didn't ask us
it's what is so helpful to understand
why this question is weird
well we think about exponential growth
or decay right
this thing is increasing but it's
slowing down right which is not usually
what you think of as exponential but
it's it's a decay model that's growing
let me say that again it's it's decaying
it's slowing down right but it's it's
actually increasing it's it's rising
right the the gradient is positive okay
and that represents my beautiful diagram
is going on that represents the fact
that more salt is going in it's
increasing but it's slowing down as it
does that okay